[Music]
in this video we'll be showing you the
latest in rstudio 1.4
and how these features can benefit you
and your team for credible
agile and durable data science results
the visual editor is one of the more
exciting new options
making working with code in our markdown
easier than ever
this new interface allows you to compose
actual r markdown
using the familiar visual interface with
it you have easy access to format
commands
inserting images tables
just to name a few of the options
available in the visual pane
continuing our theme for ease of use
when authoring
you also have the ability to find and
insert citations from multiple sources
including integration with zotero a
popular free and open source reference
manager
this not only makes a citation for you
but it also creates your bibliography
reducing the time spent in busy work
while providing research
another thing we've spent quite a bit of
time working on in our rstudio 1.4
is python which we focused more on in
our latest releases
the largest feature now available is
support for python in the environment
pane
this allows you to switch directly
between r mode and python mode in that
pane
to look at data in different
environments in r
or immediately change the view to look
at data in different modules
in python we can browse these python
modules
in the pane or open it to view directly
in our workspace
this allows you to interact with data in
python
in much the same way that you interact
with data in r
while rstudio is powered by r and will
always be in our first ide
we will continue to work to improve the
ability to use python alongside it
allowing teams to mix these languages to
suit their needs
in addition python environment
selections are now available
allowing you to select the version of
python you would like to use or switch
between at any moment
or use in each project this is all
powered by the reticulate package which
enables these python based features
in rstudio 1.4
another new feature that many users are
excited about are rainbow parentheses
which helps you to more easily view and
decipher different sections of your code
this ultimately aids in following deeply
nested constructs
allowing you to view the different
levels and find the connected pairs
in addition you can now use any model
space font you like to customize your
coding experience
allowing you to tailor the environment
to your preference
mainly designed for widescreen monitors
we also provide the ability to have
multiple source columns
in the rstudio pane layout this allows
you to take advantage of any space you
may have while avoiding the opening of
endless windows
on your screen also new in rstudio 1.4
is the command palette which allows you
to invoke any rstudio command with just
a few keystrokes
such as opening a new r markdown
document
this also allows you to very easily find
and learn custom shortcuts
that you can use in your everyday work
and increase your efficiency
one key feature that is available in
both the open source and commercial
server version of the rstudio ide
is the ability to customize where your
data and configuration are stored
for both the users and the servers
this opens up workflows for mounting
configuration within containers
helping to solve the long-standing
problem of users filling up their home
directories
and guiding content to where it should
appropriately go
moving from the open source let's also
walk through the new features that are
now available with the pro edition of
rstudio 1.4
undoubtedly the most requested and
important of our recent additions is the
ability to authenticate rstudio server
pro
now using saml this option along with
openide
enable single sign-on for users and
systems
with standardization that provides fast
yet reliable security
in addition to load balancing with a
local launcher project sharing with the
launcher is also now available
previously both of these popular
features were not available to use at
the same time
but now even when you've launcherized an
environment you can still share your
projects with others
while it still requires some setup for
permissions these are both big features
with the commercial server version of
the rstudio ide
that are now available to use at the
same time
of note for those who need to request a
gpu with slurm
this is now possible with custom s batch
parameters
another nice new feature for the
commercial server version of the rstudio
ide
is the ability to run visual studio code
sessions
this is currently in beta and is great
for those who want to run
longer form python programs while
working with other teams and projects
within the rstudio
server environment
you